hello my name is markiplier and i am
the controller the director the director
because this is bad end theater and bat
and theater is a game i was actually
sold on the reviews of this game hang on
let me see this it's overwhelmingly
positive but i was sold by a certain
review it was this one please let me
give you more money oh my [ __ ] god
please bleep me out also like add an art
book i need access to all of this art at
any given time ever
anyway so
blood gore violence and strong language
ah violence murder and death
despite this dark subject matter the
overall tone of my story is meant to be
light-hearted not too graphic and never
lingering too long in any particular
misery basically i'm the director of a
play and every play that i
put on the stage
has a bad end
of my design so i can choose your own
adventure i think
welcome to bad end theater on this stage
we shall be toying with fate you will
make many choices unlocking darker and
darker paths all in order to witness a
lovely variety of tragic events but
first allow me to explain how it works
to begin the tutorial select whichever
doll you like
okay human demon human demon human demon
humans are scarier than demons any day
you control the human doll you're a
friendly little guy just minding your
own business
how will you interact with the demon
doll
i'll play nice hostile ah play nice
you try to make friends with a demon but
it kills you in cold blood how ruthless
okay
you found your very first bad ending but
don't worry the story need not end here
let's reset the stage and try again this
time try controlling the other doll nope
[Music]
oh fine
you control the demon doll you're a
fierce looking guy just minding your own
business how will you interact with
human doll play nice
you and the human doll are able to set
aside your differences and become
friends my this isn't a bad end at all i
should have written out this possibility
now that you know how the story goes you
can set the doll's behavior in advance
as you just saw these behaviors will
automatically be set to whatever you
choose during the last playthrough but
now you can turn each one on or off
without having to replay from that
doll's perspective yes
my theater actually doubles as a puzzle
game now try turning the doll's
behaviors on and off to see different
outcomes
[Music]
go
do you understand how to play
yeah i get it
this game saves your progress
automatically so just relax and collect
all the bad endings at your own pace
now without further ado
let's start the show
okay
oh
i am
my mother once told me to do my homework
but i did not do it so i got locked in
the basement and had no food for about
two weeks in a row and i could not
escape no matter what i tried to do i
pried at the door and tried to pick the
lock and screamed for help but no one
came for me and everything was getting
dark and
i was just so tired and i was so cold
and the darkness crept through the crack
in my door to claim my soul and dragged
me kicking and screaming to the
underworld
i'm a maiden
you're a maiden you live in a peaceful
village next to speaking domain
spooky demon overlord's castle you're
told that you were fated to be captured
by the overlord one day because you were
a beautiful young girl demon overlords
apparently love capturing those you
think of how you haven't heard of that
actually happening to anyone but maybe
the demons just haven't been given the
opportunity who knows you are in church
you pray to your god asking why you have
been born into this role of maiden you
respect the divine plan and all but
you're really just curious as to what
the point of it is you're impatient
meeting a demon actually sounds pretty
gosh darn exciting maybe you'd
understand your role better if you were
just to hurry up and get captured
already
you leave a note in venture fourth to
find a demon just to you know see what
happens
not along into your little adventure
demon underling appears before you it
looks pretty scary
i'll introduce myself hi
i'm markiplier subscribe to my youtube
channel
check out this cool flannel on
cloakbrain.com you tell the demon your
name and explain your maiden from the
village the demon suddenly jumps and
starts biting a lot how painful this
plan of yours was completely stupid you
think why couldn't you have been more
patient why did you go looking for
trouble you aren't angry or anything of
course this was all your fault for
trusting a demon not to devour you on
sight this is your punishment for
questioning fate you guess bit by bit
you are swallowed by the demon until you
are no more
consumed maiden all
well i guess that is a bad end but not
nearly as dark and dreary as i would
have hoped reset
[Music]
what if i'm not polite doesn't scream at
the sight of an underling what if i'm
not polite
you're a maiden babadi booboo okay shout
for a hero to come save you
you yell but a hero does not come
the demon suddenly jumps you and starts
biting a lot
well what if i'm the hero
you're the hero you like to think of
yourself as a pretty reliable and swell
guy your life has been rather ordinary
aside from the occasional heroic
adventures fighting evil monsters and
whatnot you were told a maiden from your
village has been kidnapped and is likely
being held captive into nearby demons
overlord's castle
who even puts a village right next to
where an entire demon hernia hangs out
you don't get it you're happy to protect
the townspeople though you were born to
play this role you head off on your
adventure to rescue the maiden but demon
soldiers block your path you can kill
them to game experience
[Music]
forgetting your pride you escape with
your life but you can't return home now
your reputation will be ruined you
wonder how you'll ever be able to rescue
that maiden all the way on your own if
you can't even fight some lousy demon
underlings you'll take your chances at
the castle you're a hero after all this
your job
after a long trek you make it to the
castle's front gates you are faced with
an army of demons that all look very
intimidating there's no way to sneak
past these monsters if you want to reach
the overlord
i'll ask if they let me in
you go up to the nearest steam and it'll
explain why you've come here they stare
you down and you feel very uncomfortable
but they seem to trust you and escort
you directly to the overlord's chambers
that was easy
the overlord is alone you ask about the
maiden but the overlord doesn't seem to
know what you're talking about which you
ever really hear you wonder what could
happen to her the overlord says that she
wishes she could help you but you're the
first human that has come here in
forever at least as she knows you think
of how you probably shouldn't trust her
seeing as she's a demon and all but you
can't really prove she's lying either
you apologize for the intrusion and
return home to your village the maiden
was never found
ah well
fine
i'll murder everything in my path all
right let's kill him
ha-yah you make quick work of the vile
creatures who stood in your way you feel
much stronger now after a long trek you
make it to the castle's front gates
you're faced with an army of demons
that's all like
cutting
you gather your courage this is what
must be done in order to rescue the
maiden these are all evil demons anyway
the world is much safer with them gone
that's what you tell yourself while you
kill one after another on your way to
the overlords chambers the overlord
appears demanding to know what the hell
you're doing murdering all her soldiers
you get straight to the point and ask
her where the maiden is she feigns
ignorance a convincing act but you won't
be fooled if the maiden isn't here then
what happens to her you can see only one
answer the overlord definitely raptured
her in fact it's probably she's already
been devoured thinking about that poor
maiden's fate fills you with hatred you
fight the overlord with everything
you've got
you've become strong from the hordes of
demons you took down before this final
battle the overlords is almost no match
for you you cut it to pieces the
overlord has fallen
you breathe a sigh of relief your job is
not yet finished you search the castle
unfortunately you find no sign of the
maiden within the walls
it's just as you suspected you must have
already been devoured
you feel hollow
a great evil has been banished from this
world but
what does that matter if you were too
weak to save someone
you stand alone admits carnage
and ponder what it means to be a hero
you return to the overlord's remains and
wrap her head in your cape to bring back
to the village
[Music]
surely your great victory will be
celebrated
oh come on she was dumb and i i know
what happened to her she did get
devoured but she was also really dumb
anyway
what happens if i
okay
hear me out here what if i flee
but then try to cut through
ah same thing okay fine
fine what if i'm an underling
ah
you're a demon underling in service of
the overlord you aren't particularly
strong but not particularly weak either
that's what your friends tell you it's
your job to guard the castle and keep
humans away it's unbearably boring
heroes rarely come all the way here to
challenge the overlord anyway it's a lot
of standing in one place staring at
nothing you feel like you're gonna go
crazy if you don't get a break you
decide to ask your overlord for a day
off she gives you an earful about
responsibility and unquestioning
obedience you wait for her to finish her
lecture before returning to your post
what does she know about anything who
made her the boss of everyone you
complained about the overlord to your
friends they agree that she is a kind of
a snob and totally deserves to be kicked
off her throne you only want to defend
your frustrations but the conversation
somehow turned into an assassination
plot
you should probably steer this in a
responsible direction let's kill her
no you're sick of the overlord holding
you and your friends back you agree that
it's time for a change of management
your friends suggest maybe you should be
the new overlord you like the sound of
that you announce your first act of
rebellion is to take that day off you
wanted your friends are very impressed
you assure them you'll get you'll talk
more about the assassination thing when
you get back which satisfies them you
sneak out at the castle to have some fun
the change of atmosphere excites you you
spend some time rolling around in the
grass wild and free as you make your way
along the path to the nearby human
village you encounter a maiden she seems
very frightened and screams for a hero
to save her you consider your options
[Music]
well i do know how this goes
gobble maidens aren't the best meal but
you figure you should live up to your
demon name and strike back against the
humans you start devouring the maiden
without so much as a second thought i
feel quite proud about that other humans
would
surely praise you with curses if they
were around the sea oh man if only
someone could have been watching time to
find an audience for evil deeds you
wander into the nearby village
the people are screaming and running
away throwing rocks at you and what not
you think that's pretty rude of them you
haven't even done anything yet
put on a show you attack the nearest
human he's old and weak and his bones
crunch delightfully your audience's
screams grow louder applause you think
hey
this is actually pretty fun i should
have taken revenge like this a lot
sooner as you continue your bloodthirsty
dance striking the villagers down you
failed to notice a sword-wielding hero
running towards you he takes you out
with one swift blow you're just a demon
underling after all as you die you think
that was totally worth it that's not so
bad performer underling but now
i'm starting to see what could happen
what happens if the underling is not
hungry and i play as the maiden okay
schwem introduce yourself
you tell the demon your name and explain
that you're a maiden from the village
tell them you're thinking of
understanding your role if you were to
hurry up and get taken away by a demon
the demon doesn't seem to really have
been listening which is a little
irritating they agree to take you to
their master nonetheless after a long
walk to the castle you are introduced to
the overlord
she lectures the underling that brought
you here who was apparently told to not
leave their post
you wonder what cruel punishments awaits
them but to your surprise she lets him
off easy the underling is dismissed and
the overlord turns to you looking very
interested you explain why you've come
and she squinted you turns out she never
had any plans to capture maidens or to
do anything else that would agitate the
humans you wonder for a moment if she
might be lying but it doesn't really
seem like it still this doesn't make any
sense to you
you've always been told that demons
would one day seek you out and something
awful would happen then a hero would
come to your rescue
you don't want to believe you've been
lied to all along well lixian read that
for me maybe it's just that you haven't
been maiden like enough you asked the
overlord
what you should do to be like read this
for me you asked the overlord what you
should do to be a more suitable maiden
but she doesn't seem to understand just
go home and stop worrying about destiny
so much she makes it sound so simple
this overlord seems like the complete
opposite of you you want to learn more
about her and how she thinks you insist
on staying to talk with her more the
overlord tells you again that you should
get lost how rude you just got here
i'm not gonna do it
you put your foot down and tell her
you're not going anywhere you still want
to fulfill your destiny even if you have
to make it happen on your own she's a
little frustrated at your stubbornness
but doesn't kick you out or anything
hooray the overlord shares many stories
about demons with you and little by
little you realize they may not be the
ruthless monsters you were raised to
believe
as it turns out she commanded her demons
to avoid towns and villages
she didn't want to risk giving any
humans any excuse to send a hero out
after him
you realize that must be why you've
never heard of a demon attacking your
town
you express your gratitude to the
overlord on behalf of your village she
says you can thank her by telling the
humans to stop raising heroes she's
tired of her servants getting killed off
by them
you've always thought demons were
violent and unreasonable creatures but
seems the overlord could say the same of
humans
you may be different but really they're
just trying to live their lives the same
as you
you feel like you're starting to
understand things a lot better now
but maybe everything i've said was to
deceive you and the other humans
what would you do if i turned out to be
super evil all along
even if she were to capture you now you
think this place is far more interesting
than the way things are back home you
kind of like not being told what to
expect humans to come after you
please you feel
free
honestly you've always asked
honestly you've always kept to yourself
but spending time with this overlord has
been very nice you feel butterflies in
your stomach
as you think that a hero enters the room
you're surprised to see him at first
till you realize he must have been sent
to retrieve you
confused the hero asks what's going on
you explain the situation reassuring him
that you were never in any danger the
hero expresses his relief that this
whole misunderstanding hadn't led to any
horrible consequences you apologize for
causing trouble but really didn't anyone
read the note you left jeez the hero
asks if you'll return to the village
with him to give everyone the news of
your safety the overlord allows the two
of you to leave and you give her a
little wave as you exit the room you'll
be back soon you're about halfway back
to the village when you feel something
is off
unable to shake your concern you look
back over your shoulder
you stop in your tracks the castle is
engulfed in flames is the overlord all
right you can't return to the village
like this you have to know you have to
be sure everyone is safe you've already
taken off before the hero can even think
of stopping you
you scan the fleeing demons but the
overlord isn't among them against your
better judgment you rush into the
burning castle to find her you quickly
reach the overlord's room but the door
is shut tight the handle too hot to
touch you're too weak to force it open
you pound your face against the door
helplessly what were you thinking this
is all because you'd forgotten your role
only a hero could pull this kind of
thing off you start to cough smoke is
too thick you can hardly breathe
you realize you hadn't got much time
left you desperately head towards the
stairs to save yourself but the fire
spread faster than you expected you
won't make it outside you can't help but
laugh
what a joke
a maiden saving the overlord
if you just stayed true to your role
things wouldn't have ended like this
this is exactly the kind of punishment
you deserve
you let the demon fire cleanse your
rotten soul
[Music]
well that took a turn wait a minute
that's not the moral of this story hold
on
hold on what happens if okay yada yada
let's not tell your friends about it
about life pretty good the others not
but don't seem convinced
still gonna rebel and sneak out okay so
you still sneak out interesting
hear her out
okay
some kind of destiny bottom line
overlord
disobey
everything's cool as long as you always
listen to her from now and you're
impressed with what an easygoing boss
she is you even mention how you can't
believe you and your friends even
considered overthrowing her she gives
you a look and says and you say
that was just a joke of course she
smiles and dismisses you you decide it's
about time for a nap you don't get to
sleep long your friends wake you up rude
one of them is stepping on you pretty
hard you ask them what your deal is they
say they're planning a whole revolution
they're gonna get rid of the current
overlord and put a new ruler in place
they want to hear if you're in or out
and being a pretty lazy underling you of
course reply with that sounds like a lot
of trouble how about we just skip it
instead your friends question your
loyalty to the cause
uh she said hey she's not so bad
friends seem pretty disappointed they
apologize to you but before you can ask
them what they're sorry about one of
them suddenly seizes you
someone who's still loyal to the
overlord really has no place in our
castle you understand right the claws
tighten around your neck
you don't bother to struggle you're
outnumbered you already know how things
like this end
it's a pretty messed up thing to do to a
friend you tell them
they slit your throat in response
huh well
all right then okay so i've seen all
these perspectives i really need to see
the overlord now
you are the overlord you live in a
castle surrounded by your demon servants
it's a pretty cushy life you think
except for those pesky humans who keep
killing members of your army there's
even a role called hero whose whole
purpose in life is just to dethrone you
what's their deal anyway you've actively
avoided pissing off the humans in hopes
they'd leave you and your army alone but
they never do you're still new to the
whole overlord thing if you're really
quite honest with yourself you don't
really understand the politics of it but
you remind yourself everyone is just
doing their best to fulfill their roles
you won't let them bait you into being
of the evil overlord they expect you
think you're pretty cool and mature to
hold yourself to a higher standard like
that
one of your underlings walks into the
room totally interrupting your thoughts
about how awesome you are they're saying
something about how boring it is to
stand in one place guarding the castle
all the time especially since no one
ever comes here anyway you see their
point but the way they're whining about
it kind of bothers you what to do with
this underling
what if we grant him the day off you
tell them to take a break from the
stifling castle atmosphere and refresh
their dark soul a day off should be fine
every once in a while they thank you and
happily scurry off to do who knows what
you have nothing better to do so you
decide to nap for a little while being
the overlord sure is great
you awake to a knock at your door the
underling from earlier brought back some
company
it's a maiden from the nearby human
village she says her role is to be
captured by you the maiden then goes on
to say that she's been getting very
impatient thinking about her impending
capture so she's come here to speed
things along you appreciate her honesty
regret to inform her then you never had
any plans to capture any humans she
seems very disappointed by this perhaps
i'm not performing my role well enough
how can i become more maiden-like you
really don't understand the question you
think this world puts way too much focus
on destiny and junk just go home and
stop worrying about it you tell her the
maiden seems to be having a hard time
wrapping her head around this she
insists that she stay and talk to you
more you feel warm inside as she looks
into your eyes this is the first time a
human has looked at you without contempt
you wonder what to say
all right fine you can't bring yourself
to send this maiden away she just got
here you enjoy a nice long chat with her
sharing stories about your kind she
expresses her surprise that demons are
not all that she expected them to be
you're glad that she seems to have an
open mind about these kind of things you
also bring up how you always instruct
your army to avoid humans as not to
agitate them and get hero sent after you
that explains why the people in my
village have been left unharmed it's
because of your orders isn't it we're
very grateful you're surprised to hear
her thank you you've always thought of
humans to be violent and unreasonable
that's why your servants are always
getting killed despite your efforts to
leave them alone
but this maiden is different you joke
that maybe you've been lying to her this
whole time and that you were actually
super evil all along the maiden laughs
at that saying she wouldn't mind being
helped capture here the people in her
village are a little exhausted at times
she says you can't tell if she's into
you or not you're interrupted by another
human in your doorway this time it's a
hero he was apparently searching for the
maiden who's but we know all this this
is all things we know we know
all right let's find out what happened
i'm assuming it was some kind of
overthrow you're certain that she'll
return to spend more time with you you
just have to trust in that you decide
with the heroin maiden gone you plop
down into the comfort of your luxurious
overlord bed
your room feels so empty now
is this loneliness you hope your new
friend will be back soon
you close your eyes for a while until
your door slams shut before you know it
everything around you is being engulfed
by flames what's going on you try to
escape but someone's blocking the door
you're having trouble forcing it open
what is this someone didn't want you
getting out are you being usurped they
have zero foresight what castle will
they rule from if this one burns you
don't want to believe that your
underlings have betrayed you but there's
no accident those aren't grateful
bastards you choke on the thick black
smoke from the fire you can't believe
you're being done in by a bunch of
cowards you'll see them in hell
okay well yeah i'm burned
i'm burned then
okay but we're we're unlocking more and
more options here as we go hang on what
happens if hm
let me see something
she's surprised oh right i made her nice
i forgot
hear her out wait
okay
to decide they seem to be getting along
just fine time for your nap and then
this
okay let's kill the overlord
you tell them you're just joking clarify
that you're totally in to win it they
say you were always terrible with jokes
whether or not you actually feel like
killing the overlord you know how bad
it'd be to end up on the wrong side of
things and if this assassination deal
doesn't pan out you can always pretend
you were innocent all along
but beneath your shield of faux
confidence you're worried that you're
getting yourself dragged into you follow
your friends outside the castle to talk
more about the plan you're curious if
they have any idea how they want to do
this they figure they'd just lock her in
a room and set it on fire what a stupid
plan that could go wrong in so many ways
you realize your friends are just a
bunch of directionals less thugs useless
without someone's guidance your guidance
there'd probably be casualties if you
fought her head-on and while showy desks
make a revolution a heck of a lot more
fun it's probably the wrong way to go
your friends agree and suggest that they
play the assassin that you played the
assassin you really didn't want it to
come down to this but you can't back
down now you'll have to be the one to
assassinate the overlord besides no one
has any better ideas you sneak into the
overlords room
she's taking a nap
like usual this is almost too easy you
silently approach your master she looks
so peaceful time to die
you figure the cleanest way to do this
would be to dig your claws into her
throat so you do just that she wakes up
but not in time to stop you you watch as
she chokes on her blood
cursing you before finally expiring
that felt terrible
you remind yourself it was either her or
you and you weren't about to let
yourself get killed by anyone you leave
the room to find your friends just
waiting outside they look pleased only
now do you realize they mustn't plan to
use you like this from the beginning you
are the new ruler of this castle your
subjects bow before you you live in fear
that they will one day betray you as you
had betrayed your overlord
[Music]
interesting so
i'm gonna go back to this hold on okay
let's kill
chicken out you don't want to kill her
you can't go through with it you turn to
leave the room but you find your friends
blocking the exit in a panicked whisper
you ask them to let you out this seems
to have been their way of testing your
loyalty you tell them that this is
pretty [ __ ] up and asks to be let out
again the overlord stirs in her bed
while your head is turned the demon shut
the door
you scramble into the overlord's closet
to hide before she wakes up and sees you
that's nothing you could possibly say to
explain this and survive
you're trembling you can't believe those
[ __ ] would bully you like this you
feel like crying
light flickers at your feet it doesn't
take you long to realize they've set the
room on fire you hear the overlord
trying to get the door open to no avail
you're both trapped too afraid to move
you resign yourself to your fate
you and the overlord burn together
fascinating okay
so
right
yeah
right we're gonna be maiden
we're gonna go into this introduce
yourself
wait reset okay what happens if wait
what happens if i shout for a hero
you yell him is put off of your sudden
shouting
uh no that's the same okay okay okay
okay so if i change
this
to dutiful and not diplomatic what
happens then
here barges into the room his clothes
are stained by a dark liquid it's
dripping from his weapon too you realize
it must be demon blood something
horrible has happened confused the hero
asks you what's going on you explain the
situation reassuring him that you're
never in any danger
the overlord has walked past the hero
and out into the hall she's wailing you
can only guess what kind of horrible
scene she's left for her
the overlord tears the hero apart in
retaliation you watch silently unable to
scream the overlord who you had just
been getting along with so well has
killed another human right in front of
you it's clear now that you have been
deceived by your sweet words demons are
ruthless monsters after all well i don't
know about that because of the whole
murdering your entire
castle
friends family
i've been fair is fair here you somehow
managed to slip past the overlord and
make it out of the blood-soaked castle
you never look back
interesting what happens if you do all
this
but underling is disloyal oh
near the castle's entrance you spy a
group of suspicious demons congregating
they're talking about assassinating the
overlord you have to warn her
but the hero shakes his head he says
that if this is the true nature of
demons the world is better off with less
of them this isn't right you think what
kind of hero passes up the chance to
save a life the demons have taken notice
of you now or never you take off into
the castle and the unreliable hero falls
shortly after you burst into the
overlord's room all of your words
spilling out at once you should probably
slow down but there's no time the
overlord seems to have followed your
frantic explanation but clearly doesn't
understand the urgency of the situation
the underling you recognize from before
barges in calling you a liar you're
surprised they were part of this evil
plot they seemed so nice the other
demons come right in after them saying
the whole thing was the first
underling's idea everyone's shouting at
each other now it's really stressing you
out you relieve when the overlord
demands silence she threatens them with
violence and you think she is very
overlord-like in this moment the group
of demons hiss at each other before
shutting the door leaving the little one
behind
you watch as it pounds on the door in
distress
have they locked you all in you have a
bad feeling about this
and thinking that must have jinxed it
because now the room is engulfed in
flames if only you had ignored those
doing demons before you and the hero
wouldn't have stumbled into this
situation if you had just pretended not
to hear them if you left as you were
told only overlord would have been
killed but you couldn't have done that
that path
isn't an option for you you think that
no matter what you'll always strive for
the path where everyone survives if it
exists it must exist it simply must the
overlord seizes her underling they beg
for their life you pray you don't know
what else to do so you just pray
the overlord's claws pierce the
underling's chest they scream an awful
scream
she digs and twists her claws into the
poor thing while you continue to pray
but there's no saving any of you know
you the overlord the hero and the
underlings corpse
are consumed by flames
devout maidenhead well i'm
i know it's called bad end theater but i
gotta think that there's some kind of a
you know
good ending so there's got to be some
differences with being the overlord
right
so get back to work
give them a lecture about responsibility
and unquestioning obedience your
servants have to do what they're told
whether they like it or not keeper here
interesting
the maiden came here to be captured by
you didn't she you'll grant her wish you
tell the hero you won't let him take her
home the maiden assures you that she'll
be back but you don't budge
the hero is cautious now if you won't
let her go maybe you demons are evil
after all and if you are
i'll be forced to vanquish you
you have no choice you destroy the hero
before he can steal your maiden away
she's frightened you don't understand
why didn't she say she prefers this
place to her village now she doesn't
have to leave
you take a step towards the maiden and
she backs herself into a corner you
don't understand
she wanted to stay here with you the
hero was trying to get in the way of
that you had to kill him you'll be sure
to keep this maiden very safe from now
on
[Music]
well
selfish overlord and be
i've seen a few of those
there's got to be a way to get the end a
maybe that's the good ending who knows
what happens if we've got a dutiful hero
but we're the overlord right
give him day off
let her stay you notice the sounds of
battle have started ringing through the
castle halls the maiden is getting
nervous but you reassure that it's only
your underling's roughhousing no big
deal you know it's probably a hero but
you don't want to upset the maiden by
telling her that your army will take
care of it
it isn't long before the hero bursts
into your room but he shouldn't have
made it here why didn't they stop him
the hero just stands there unsure of
himself he is covered in demon blood as
the main speaks to him trying to explain
the situation you move past the hero and
out the door
you're not thinking clearly seeing your
servants bodies and pieces all strewn
about
that hero did this has so much blood why
did he come for the maiden do you think
she needed rescuing there's no one for
this hero to save here there's never any
harm meant to anyone you were just
talking to her
why is it turned out like this
the hero starts babbling insincere
apologies and excuses realizing his
wrongdoing but you are far beyond
hearing that kind of [ __ ]
you've had it with these humans always
murdering your servants for no reason
you can no longer hold yourself back and
lash out at the hero
when you regain control there's nothing
left of the hero
the maiden has fled in terror
you're alone
but like i said before fair is fair i've
only gotten 13
13 endings there must be like two other
options here
oh what happens if i go home
obey her
you don't want to cause any trouble so
you figure it's best time to go home
along the way you encounter a hero he
asks what you're doing don't you know
the overlord's castle is like right
there you explain everything that
happened the hero seems to think you're
lying to him he asked if you've been
brainwashed by the demons what a nerve
you're very upset that this so-called
hero treat you this way and leave it off
you return to the village alone everyone
is very worried about you they surround
you with a thousand questions and you
tell them your story as you explain that
the overlord never had any intentions to
harm anyone here you notice the looks of
uncertainty in the crowd people are
whispering things to each other while
you speak to them you are loudly
interrupted by an older man he rudely
calls you a demon sympathizer the crowd
is growing unruly you don't understand
you've only told them the truth do they
not believe you
everyone begins speculating what must
have actually happened they weave of
elaborate lies and ask you to prove your
innocence
how could you have returned without the
aid of a hero they ask you could not
have possibly escaped from the overlords
on your own without harm
you must be conspired with the demons so
i had to say everyone believing that
they are horrible creatures we know them
be so they say
have the people of your village always
been this blinded by their fears and
hatreds of things they've never cared to
know you wonder how you missed that
before you're seized by the crowd and
voices from all sides are calling for
public execution you were to be burned
at the stake oh god you don't want to
die you wonder would it have been better
to hide the truth you don't like the
thought of that you've always lived
honestly so why has this happened why
are you being punished
you hear the dissenting voices of your
family and neighbors but they like you
are powerless against the momentum they
can only watch as you burn
and you can only cry for them
you are so
so sorry
[Music]
well that was sad
what happens if
dude of doodle hero
dude possessive
ah objection to the hero's suggestion
you tell her you plan on returning soon
but she isn't having it you feel nervous
the hero puts on a brave face for you if
you won't let her go maybe you demons
are evil after all and if you are i'll
be forced to vanquish you leave you
leave me no choice the overlord suddenly
jumps a hero she tears into him with her
claws
you want to grab with the scream catches
in your throat you watch because you
can't look away has you really been
lying to you all along
you wonder if this is your punishment
for questioning the divine plan
the overload approaches you now you back
yourself into a corner her expression is
complicated being captured by the
overlord in a horrible way like this
was your destiny after all she vows to
keep you very safe from now on you're
afraid to find out what that means but
there's no one left to save you
you belong to the overload now
captured maiden a
it's the other side of the story it's
the other side of the same story that's
what a b is
got it
15. okay so if if
i'm the hero right
right okay
flee like a coward ask if they'll let me
in
and here's the maiden
wasn't there before you all look at each
other in surprise and confusion this is
no time to hesitate oh
well what's going on
okay okay okay
objects you leave me no choice you
overload pauses before suddenly jumping
you you're helpless as she disembowels
you with your claws how horrible you
came all this way only to bed with this
cruel fate you should have destroyed
these creatures while you had a chance
your dying wishes for the maiden to
somehow make it out of this alive
naive hero
all right what if i'm not a naive hero
what if i'm not
flee
let me in
killer you launch forward driving your
blade through the evil overlord she
screams then falls silent
the overlord has been slain
you smile offering your hand to the
maiden
she takes it after slight hesitation
she must be surprised at how strong you
are you escort the maiden home she's
oddly quiet on the trek back to the
village
she must be too shy to speak how
the villagers are very pleased with what
a good job you've done slaying the
overlord and saving a hostage they throw
a huge celebration in your name
you are remembered for generations as
the greatest hero the village has ever
seen
now what if we do
this
here enters the room here suddenly
dashes towards the overlord sword run
oh
no
how you
selflessly throw yourself in front of
the hero's blade
acting as a shield
it's funny you think
you never could have imagined this would
be the way that you would die
the rules are all swished around but it
feels right to you somehow you're glad
your destiny turned out to be saving
someone rather than being saved yourself
as your vision fades you hope that
everything turns out all right for your
new friend
oh still what i would say is a bad end
but what does this look like from the
other
stare
side
while here comes ah before you even know
how to react he makes his move and the
maiden makes hers
she used her own body to shield you from
the hero's blade
why why has this happened the maiden
falls to the floor lifeless as the pool
of blood when ether grows so does your
rage the hero has taken something
precious from this world you lose
control and the hero is
obliterated
but your hatred for the humans has naian
been sated
you go on to destroy them all
and become ruler of the entire world
well now what does it look like from the
hero
you launch forward to put an end to the
evil overlord but your blade pierces the
maiden instead yes sacrificed herself to
protect this demon
it takes you a moment to recover from
the shock the overlord whales
why did you do that you're not sure if
the question is directed at you the
overload strikes at you in vengeful rage
you parry
and she's slain
your sword feels heavy you look at your
hands
your clothes
blood
so much blood
you look at the fallen maiden wondering
what to tell the town's people
which why would she protect the overlord
she must have been brainwashed by
demonic magic
you pick up the overlord's head wrapping
it in your cape and begin your long
journey back to town
you will say that you were too late that
nothing could be done for the girl but
the overlord is slain
it will be a celebration
[Music]
well that's sad okay so i'm assuming i
have all the combinations now what
happens if you get there
but the maiden decided to leave
right
on your oh there she is on your way back
to the overlord's castle you spot a
maiden heading back towards the village
she couldn't have come from the
overlord's castle could she this may be
the extract mating you're looking to
seek into rescue you approach her with
curiosity that's what she's doing but if
we know this okay she can't be trusted
you aren't sure you should listen to
this maiden you've been taught your
whole life that demons are evil you ask
her if she she's sure about all this but
she gets very upset that you think she
would lie to you
she storms off before she could ah you
decide to return to the village certain
that she must have been kidnapped maiden
you were sent to rescue glad that took
care of itself you take your time
walking home job well done today you
think of yourself as you walk past the
town square you notice the whole village
is crowded around
is that the maiden you saw earlier she's
bound to a wooden stake the crowd is in
a frenzy smoke begins to rise and you
stand idly by his flames consume the
maiden
she must have done something horrible to
deserve that she seemed nice though you
think but evil comes in all forms you
reassure yourself
you decide to call it a day and return
to your house
but you can't escape the sinking feeling
maybe you aren't cut out for this rule
okay okay okay
okay okay
believe
you have no reason to assume she's been
lying to you even though her story is
kind of hard to believe you feel you
should trust her you tell her she's
you're pretty surprised that everyone
has been wrong about demons all along
the town's people must be informed of
this immediately the two of you returned
to the village that had all been so
worried they praise you for your bravery
but the maiden quickly sets a record
straight there was nothing she needed to
be rescued from in the first place the
villagers looked to you for explanation
you politely informed them that isn't
your story to tell you melee ran into
her on the way to the castle she
explains that the overlord isn't
interested in capturing maidens or
anything of the sort
the villagers turn to you again in
disbelief they aren't being subtle in
how little they trust this maiden's
story you totally believe her but to
placate these fair citizens you
volunteer to speak to the demons
personally
just in case the crowd breaks into
hushed whispers you're too busy thinking
what a great and reliable hero you are
to hear them what they're saying
the town's elder voice breaks you out of
your own thoughts he implores you to
meet with the overlord immediately and
says they'll keep an eye on the maiden
until you return
you figure that sounds all right but the
mood is kind of intense for some reason
did you miss something you aren't sure
what's going on but you get the feeling
it might be bad to leave the maiden on
her own
but she suddenly takes off running oh
you thought the two of you were in this
together her actions have convinced the
crowd that she's obviously been a liar
and a witch from the start people are
shouting for you to hunt her down and
her demon friends down already but that
doesn't sound like a very heroic task
you can't help but feel these people are
wrong it's up to you to catch her and
talk to the demons in order to clear up
this misunderstanding you valiantly dash
after the maiden towards the overlord's
castle
the air becomes dark and thick as you
enter deep into the demon territory evil
miasma no you realize it's just normal
smoke you see the maiden head when she's
stopped and retracts
the overlord's castle is engulfed in
flames
you had only taken an eye off the main
for a second but she's already
disappeared you get closer to the castle
but the smoke is too thick you think of
turning back
the maiden might need your help you can
barely see
she could be impossible to find
she
could have been lying to you all along
was this a trap would it be worth
risking your life on that chance
your legs feel heavy
no
going in there would be suicide you will
return to the villagers and tell them
there was nothing you could do
you were too light
the maiden was claimed by the demons
god damn it i'm getting closer guys
those are four oh my god there's four
choices now oh no okay
[Music]
there's four choices now what if we're
the maiden again
introduce yourself
obey her relieve
for surprises demonstrating is malicious
okay so this is the other side of this
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes okay
ah that's what happens here let's go
ahead and get this one
you prove yourself without anyone's help
make a run for the overlord's castle
leaving the hero behind but as you get
closer you start to notice the tower
bladder
and you die
oh no and now you die
ah interesting okay
now we're gonna go back in grab the hero
and run you boldly announce that you'll
accompany the hero to prove yourself
you'd rather risk what's going on there
than instead of staying in a village
that doesn't trust you no one seems to
know how to react you grab the hero by
the wrist and take off before anyone
stops you but as you approach the castle
you notice something's gone terribly
wrong it appears to be on fire is the
overlord alright you have to be sure
everyone is safe you've already taken
off before the hero can even think of
stopping you
you scan the fleeing demons but the
overlord isn't among them against your
better judgment oh no
what were you thinking
what were you thinking
what were you thinking what happens if
we're the underling but the hero has a
no
yes
for fiora sleeper we a battle you emerge
from a room to find a hero slaughtered
many of your friends and work associates
what a jerk
hey
stop that
you lunge at him while he's busy driving
the sword into a garden someone
sometimes brought you food whenever they
noticed you were feeling kind of down
you like that guard you wish to thaw
your demon heart for this hero to suffer
for his deeds you bite into him tearing
his flesh from bone it tastes like iron
hear struggles you feel a sword go
through you but there's no pain only
retribution more of your comrades pile
onto him as your consciousness fades
the hero is overtaken your army has won
you've earned your rest oh
well that's a good ending what happens
if you don't save yourself you look
around at the lifeless forms of those
you've known as far back as you can
remember you feel glad to not be in
their shoes you also feel guilty to be
thinking that you flee the castle until
you remember your role not as an
underling but as a demon this kind of
thing is expected of you maybe you'll
start a new life far away from any
humans or demons where you'll live
peacefully alone in some deep dark
forest somewhere oh
well that's another ending at least at
least i'm not dead okay
24 or 41. i'm more than halfway down i
don't know what these question marks are
but i do know that there's a way to kind
of combine these i i know
see if i do uh
select the character to display their
timeline
huh
oh
ahaha
that's helpful
diplomatic heroic
got it
okay this is helpful
diplomatic heroic
let's see this one
[Music]
oh
you didn't even have a seat oh you've
gone soft how could you've laid your
guard down like that
how unfair after all you've done to
avoid this outcome you can't outrun your
destiny the hero is always slays the
overlord
you should never have trusted a human
you watch as the hero escorts the maiden
out of your castle
captured by a demon at least she got
what she came here for you join your
army in eternal slumber
ah ah yeah okay i haven't even gotten
the basic ones hungry
okay all right get back to work
you wake up to a huge commotion hero oh
rush out into the battlefield to
confront this jerkwad you cursed him and
very rudely inquires reasons for doing
all this hero yells at you demanding you
return the maiden you're holding captive
you don't know what he's talking about
but you can't forgive his actions you do
battle with the hero but he has grown
strong from cutting down your army
you're unable to defeat him with a
decisive wing swing he stabbed you and
cut through the piece of you fall you've
failed your subject
you've spit karthith weakly and you wish
you'd have been stronger maybe you never
suited for the overlord in the first
place truth was you were never that much
more powerful than the demons who served
you it was the title the control that
gave you strength these are your
thoughts as you're swallowed by the
darkness
all right well that's
that is something
ah
right
okay diplomatic possessive granting okay
hey
gobbler
wait no what was it i forget
diplomatic okay
disloyal
oh noes bring the right it was bring to
the castle yeah oh aha but there's a
couple of humans in there you watch the
scene unfold you're unsure why but the
overlord suddenly cuts down the hero she
approaches the maiden you brought to her
earlier with the overlords distracted
you figure this is good at chances any
and you launch a sneak attack getting
her right in the back she flinches
giving you enough advantage to take her
down you rip the overlord apart until
she stops moving
that was messier than you would have
liked the maiden mutters something from
the corner
thank you for saving me it wasn't your
attention but it sounds like you did
something heroic you tell the maiden to
go home this place is dangerous she
follows your advice and leaves the
castle
your castle you are the new overlord
[Music]
interesting okay we're really getting
him now okay resolute okay disloyal
anti-social obedient okay okay
anti-social obedient okay okay trusting
okay trusting okay
let's go
you and your friends turn to notice a
pair of humans have overheard your
entire conversation they take off into
the castle are they headed to the
overlords room [ __ ]
the overlord will kill you for sure if
she found out you were conspiring to
take her out you dash into the castle
after the humans sure enough the
maiden's already frantically telling the
overlord everything you shout that the
humans are liars your friends soon
arrive to back you up except they don't
instead they blame you for the whole
thing they cried that it was all your
idea and that they were just going all
with the flow too scared to refuse your
crazy plan
you can't believe they'd tell the
overlord such a blatant lie you always
knew better than to trust them you're
the one who didn't have a choice here
you all shouted each other until the
overlord demands silence
regardless of who led this conspiracy i
have no choice but to punish everyone to
keep you all in your place be crushed
but he's my heel
she sounds tough but lately all she does
is sleep you doubt her strength you hear
our traitorous friends mutter something
about going back to plan a and suddenly
the door slams shut you're trapped in
here with the overlord and the two
humans then the room bursts in flames
you pound on the door screaming curses
at those who betrayed you the hero joins
you vowing to slay the lot of them you
wish you'd get that chance the overlord
grabs you by the throat you cry for
mercy you were forced into this mess
you're sure now that they would have
killed you if you decided with her but
the overlord doesn't hear your pleas she
drives her claws into your chest at
least she made it quick
okay well what if what if
traitor underling yeah you get that but
what if okay what if you're not resolute
here we go same thing turn notice the
maiden from earlier has overheard your
entire conversation it'd be bad for you
if the overlord found out about this
use the maiden for killing practice it
was usually made for killing practices
just the way it has to be you declare
you before jumping or inclining your
guts
turns out you're already an expert at
ending lies your friends call you a show
off you go back to the castle wash off
the icky human blood as you're finishing
up that you hear the sounds of battle
outside a hero has come seeing the dead
maiden must have made him pretty angry
you get to thinking if this hero took
down the overlord for you everything
might actually work out in your favor
you wait for things to die down outside
before poking your head out
you spot the overlord and hero locked in
battle they've worn each other down
making this very easy for you
once an opening it presents itself you
hit the back of the ears head knocking
about what are you doing couldn't you
tell this was a duel you don't respond
you have to carry out the assassination
you tackle her and rip her to shreds
with your claws until she helps move in
you finish off the hero next you can't
let him revive and come after you later
kind of a cheap victory but it doesn't
make any difference
anyone who managed to survive comes
crawling out from their hiding places
you're the new ruler you live in the
fear that they will one day betray you
okay
that's a that's that's a but what about
there was another one captor
captor i don't even remember there being
something about capture saucer in the
dungeon you and your friend seized the
maiden and bring her to the dungeon
under the castle it's empty save for the
decorative skulls not only there to make
it feel more spooky the maiden is very
upset you leave her in the cell that
continue scheming with your friends but
now a hero has arrived at the front
gates he's asking about a maiden perhaps
if everyone you just locked up
the gatekeeper who must have seen
everything tells the hero exactly what
happened what an idiot you think why
give the hero an excuse to start
slaughtering us the hero yells prepare
to face justice and the other such
cliche hero lines before driving a sword
into the gatekeeper's torso
you're small compared to a lot of your
friends so you're able to slip away
without getting cut up by that sword
you get thinking this hero took down the
overload for ah
it's the same thing
but there is a capture factor okay
how do i get
to play as the maiden
thrown in jail i have to leave
[Music]
leave
leave on your own no that just goes
there
okay what about what about that
ah
[Music]
a suspicious group of demons stands just
outside the entrance they're talking
about assassinating the overlord they
immediately notice you overheard them
and decide to lock you in the jungle
before you can cause any trouble
ah
so sad
battle
if he's out there your cries don't reach
him after a while the violence seems to
die down
it's impossible to tell what's happened
you continue to wait but no one comes
for you
unable to escape
you rot in that cell
but i found a way for the flames not to
burn
yes okay
i know i could just chase these down
and there must be four secret endings
there must be where's the loot trusting
obedient anti-social obedient
anti-social
okay
it must be a secret trait of hers that
we have not seen yet
interesting i'm gonna cut cause it's
taking longer than i thought i'm gonna
cut but i'm gonna finish this in another
recording so
mysteriously disappearing
i've always been here
everything is the same
don't worry why i'm out of breath
okay so where were we we have 29 of 41
endings we
i thought oh right we need to get
another
ah
another choice for
you
so what could this mean okay
anti-social go home obedient so they do
go home
ah
so
play
here
overlord
right
okay day off oh
what
you're wigging but one of your
underlings are here wishes to speak with
you he inquires about a mayman huh
sophie and sleep oh
[Music]
uh
you gave this one a day off and this is
how it repays you you die wondering if
you could have done anything to prevent
this um
well
all right
i didn't expect that to happen
uh oh right hungry
what if we go
[Music]
thank god this guide is here okay what
if uh not obedient is that way is that
what it actually needs let them go
spend more time with you you just have
to trust in that you decide okay
well that's the same okay there's
something that i'm missing here
trusting resolute okay
that's what's needed i need these other
things i think something absolutely this
is what i need
i think i gotta let them stay
and then let them go
because they'll be back ah the maiden
suddenly bursts into your room
accompanied by a hero she's trying to
frantically communicate something to you
but you're still half sleep they tell
you a group of demons is after your life
you still don't grasp the urgency of the
situation one of your underlying barges
is in next shouting that the humans are
liars
okay i've seen this
everyone's shouting over
okay regardless of who led this
conspiracy i have no choice but to
punish everyone okay okay
still unsure you have the
strength to back it up okay you the
maiden the hero and one of your
underlings are trapped inside okay
said i burned alive in your own room by
those you thought you could trust you
should have expected this from a bunch
of idiot demons though you notice the
maiden crying why does she have to die
over something that has nothing to do
with her perhaps she was cursed from the
moment she spoke to you you wonder if
you're cursed as well you're so filled
with anger and frustration you don't
even notice you've grabbed the underling
those traitors blamed everything on they
cry for mercy saying that they were
dragged into this plot knowing they'd be
killed if they took your side they cried
that they didn't want to have to kill
you you almost feel sorry for them
oh
i'll forgive them
you release the underling killing them
wouldn't make you feel any better
besides they've already gotten their
punishment you'll all burn to go
overlord's true end true and true ending
oh what no stop
what are you doing don't do this to me
before you're taken back to the reset
the story once again you pause for a
moment true i
okay i feel called out here
and i don't like that true and you say
to yourself what was the point of all my
effort if the true ending is this
terrible you must have forgotten where
you were
this is bad end theater is the pain
setting on oh
but you should have been well aware of
what you were shown when you entered
this place it's a problem i've seen
quite often at some point you grew
attached to my little cast you started
to relate to their flaws their plights
he started wishing for their happiness
but you aren't going to find that in my
theater my lovingly crafted labyrinth of
suffering
anyway i hope you'll pardon the
interruption you're making great
progress the choice to continue on to
the next ending is always yours i'll
leave it to you dear guest well ominous
floating crying head
i have something to say about that you
have no idea how boneheaded i can be all
right well as ominous as that was
puppet master
puppet master you say
well well well
the true end you say
but what about the other one that's
probably just the other the other side
of the equation here
stay away listen let them go take
retribution
you pierce your chest with your colossal
scream the hero backs away he's wise not
to interfere they stop moving but you
keep digging and twisting your claws
into them doesn't make you feel any
better the underlings course burns along
with you and the two humans okay i just
needed to get that other ending because
spiteful overlordanic not the true
ending of course
but i needed to get that other one
because now i have a choice to be
merciful here
i'm wondering
there's something else here trusting
diplomatic what if you're not resolute
let's try that
oh yeah oh i didn't change the
minions settings
oh this is new anyway you've almost
fallen asleep when the maiden and the
hero burst into your room frantically
trying to communicate something to you
you're told that a group of demons is
plotting to assassinate you you're not
surprised how nice are the humans to
care though underling barges in well
this seems the same hero trot pounds on
the door as well vowing to slay the
cowardly demons on the other side
huh
[Music]
well that seemed like the same
why did that seem that no matter the
perspective the true ending remains the
same that's what makes it true you
couldn't resist seeing it for yourself
though could you i wonder what will
happen when you collect them all will
you give in to despair or
or what
also i don't know why that was different
why is that different
okay disloyal trusting go home and is
obedient
right okay
right okay because that would change her
and the hero's interaction
go home
sounds a battle heroes cutting your way
through
well this is interesting vile demons i
should have shouldn't have believed for
a second that you were anything but pure
evil i'll exterminate you all
you don't really know what he's gone to
about but you engage regardless of girls
got to defend her people you clash again
and again but the hero isn't going down
easily you're both dangerously low on
health waiting for the others to make a
move when one of your underlings appears
behind him they knock the euro
unconscious you kind of appreciate it
but can't they see this was duel
they don't respond you sense murderous
intent oh
your servant tackles you tearing you
apart with a claws you struggle to
retaliate they've done too much damage
you can barely move now your blood is
everywhere you can't believe this has
happened to you
why has this happened to you you've been
slain by your own underling
well a letter flutters down from beyond
the curtains you found lost letter
number four i'm sorry
my love do you remember when we first
met
i just finished one of my scripts one i
was quite proud of in fact
as i read it aloud you happen to pass by
what a terrible ending you said why
should all those poor fools have to die
you were so rude you wouldn't accept any
of my justifications yet
you managed to convince me it really
would have been better if everyone could
live in harmony however unrealistic that
felt
i looked back fondly on that day even
now
i wonder if somewhere you're thinking of
it too forever yours
tragedy
tragedy and comedy
tragedy comedy that obviously the sad
crying face is the tragedy mask without
the comedy mask
oh i see
i see i see
i
see
[Music]
uh
let's kill the overlord to your surprise
the overlord spares you
or maybe she'd rather see you suffer
instead looking around you've just gone
from one dead end to another the maiden
is crying the hero is silent
you all burn together
okay well i've seen that underling's
true end i see
a letter flutters down from beyond the
curtain you found lost letter number
three i'm really going backwards on this
i've been feeling a little depressed
lately many patrons have come to my
theater but none so far have stayed to
experience every tale in its entirety
the critics haven't exactly been kind
but i understand
my stories aren't exactly crowd pleasers
despite that you always listen to the
very end
i'm grateful for that
hope to see you again soon
forever yours
tragedy
well boo hoo maybe you should write
happier stories then okay beautiful
heroic okay anti-sochi
anti-sochi
staying
beautiful hiroro
okay
beautiful hiroro
[Music]
so she okay
hello
okay bye bye
he's covered in demon blood oh god yeah
that's right he's dutiful you are
frightened by the sight of him and run
away you return to the village alone
everyone was very worried about you they
surround you with a thousand questions
and you tell them your story as you
explain that the overlord never had any
intentions to harm anyone here you
notice the looks of uncertainty in the
crowd people are whispering things to
each other while you speak to them you
are loudly interrupted by an older man
oh
i did something wrong oh i stay with the
overlord that's what i did wrong okay
hi
um no i'm staying okay
dude do nothing
here's blade piece i thought i got this
one overlord is slain hero smiles and
holds out of sandy you saying it's time
to go home his glove is drenched in
blood hesitantly you take his hand the
hero guides you through the castle past
the corpses of his enemies you try to
keep your eyes at your feet there's
blood everywhere you shut your eyes but
even then
you can't escape this smell
all of this
was because of you wasn't it you exit
the castle and the hero leads you back
to the village
everyone celebrates the heroes great
triumph over the demons
you feel sick
but you take part in the festivities
regardless
oh
complacent maiden well you know
there are worse fates i've seen them
that's not so bad okay what is this
okay leave trusting
return
disloyal and oh
hi bye
leave on your own okay
i see assassination plot immediately
notice you overheard them and decide to
lock you in the dungeon before you can
cause any trouble you cry out but the
demons ignore your protests you can't
believe you escaped possibly being
thrown in a cell block in your village
only to be tossed in this awful place
this is terrible who's going to keep
those demons from harming the overlord
you hope she can fend for herself
you sure can't hear the sounds of battle
echoing through the halls outside did
the hero follow you if he's out there
you cries don't reach him after a while
the violence seems to die down it's
impossible to tell what happened you
continued wave when no one comes for you
unable to escape you brought in that
cell
okay i already got that one ah disloyal
but not captor that's what's different
bye bye
goodbye
okay
uh this is just the way it has to be
they suddenly attack you in that moment
you regret everything ever
i die instantly
i'm dead now okay so i gotta get
disloyal
you can get here a couple different ways
trusting resolute disloyal
merciful that's the only real difference
here i see
okay the overlord spares the underling
you feel relieved but doesn't make any
difference you will all burn together
maiden's true end i see
a letter flutters down from beyond the
curtain you found lost letter number two
it can't end like this
i'll keep collecting bad endings for now
my love
i finally fulfilled the childhood dream
of mine yeah that's right i opened up my
very own theater you'd be so proud if
you can only see it
i know how much it would have meant to
you to be at my side on opening night
i'm sorry for going ahead without you
but i thought
if my theater could become world famous
then maybe
you just might hear of it
wherever you are
forever yours
tragedy
is whatever okay there's a lot of
different things here okay so
i got to be dutiful
and then apologize
okay here we go
[Music]
ah
not wanting to look like you're a crazy
person chasing after anything you
nonchalantly walk back to town as you
walk past the town square you notice the
whole village is crowded around is that
the maiden you saw earlier oh
she's bound to a wouldn't
i thought i
i thought she went back to the
well she went back to the castle wasn't
that what was that what i saw it kind of
stopped and uh
what if you're not obedient okay here we
go
okay you can't sense anything sinister
happening you all look at each other in
surprise and confusion this is no time
to hesitate
uh
what's going on she explains that she
came here on her own and was never in
any danger she hesitantly asked why
you're covered in blood you don't know
how to respond the overlord moves past
you and out the door to see your army in
lifeless bloody piles she's wailing it's
horrible is your chance hero
[Music]
bob sorry you hope she'll let this whole
thing slide if you could just explain
yourself you really try but the overlord
is inconsolable she tears you apart and
the maiden watches in silence as you die
you can't help but think you probably
deserved this
[Music]
alright so this is other way anti-sochi
what if you're i think it's like
not polite okay but obedient got it not
resolute let's try that
[Music]
i believe you
when you reach the gates you ask the
demons if they've seen the maiden they
have they inform you she's being held in
the dungeon at the moment she trusts
them and in return they lock her up so
demons are truly evil beings after all
you demand they take you to her but they
do not let you pass you should have
expected as much from these unreasonable
creatures you know what you must do you
thrust your blade through the demon
before you and rush the castle alone
you're the only one who can save the
maiden now
what the [ __ ] are you doing killing all
my soldiers the overlord is angry you
vow to exterminator and all of demon
kind you clash again and again but the
overlord isn't going down easily you're
both dangerously low on health when
everything goes black your quest has
come to an abrupt end
ow
[Music]
hey what the hell okay but what if
resolute not captor same deal spy group
is suspicious demons they're talking
about assassinating the overlord this
proves that you to you that demons
really are foul creatures we have to
tell her about this you don't understand
what the maiden is thinking the world is
better off with less demons they're all
cold ruthless creatures that should be
destroyed and those same creatures have
just noticed you eavesdropping the
maiden takes off into the castle and you
have no choice but to follow you burst
into the overlord's room maiden
frantically tries to communicate what
you just heard a demon i know this i
know this yadda yadda everyone's
shouting uh okay gonna kill
right let's go okay you'll all burn
together wow
here is true end
okay but uh that wasn't all the endings
there's one more ending here that i have
no
there's an offshoot ending here so
you're not obedient
[Music]
you're disloyal
[Music]
you're merciful right okay same deal
diplomatic
step up to the near steam and explain
why you've come here they stare you down
you feel very uncomfortable but they
seem to trust you i've done this
uh
what's going on
we leave casually exit the castle ah
here we go
you don't understand what the maiden is
thinking the world is better off
aha i think i've wait
wait
wait there's something going on here
what if he's not disloyal
[Music]
no that's kind of a requirement
unless you go the other nah he's
disloyal in either one of them how do
you get that one okay let me think about
this the maiden overhears the underlings
plot to kill the overlord and goes back
to warn her
what is this
what
what if not possessive try to make
conversation with maiden but she's
pretty quiet since leaving the overlords
room is she shy she suddenly stops in
her track and you turn to ask what the
deal is oh
wait this is different though i can't
skip it you can't help but feel relieved
you got the maiden now when you did but
she suddenly takes off towards the
castle smoke is so thick what's she
thinking i have done that
[Music]
everyone's everything
[Music]
nope okay so by process of elimination i
know that i have to get to this point to
be able to get this ending there's not
really a choice here so it must be
something else
that exists it has to have you be
disloyal that's a must you could be a
tyrant you could be anti-social you
could be
not you could not be possessive that's
the thing you couldn't be possessive
but you could be merciful which seems to
be the requirement for the true ending
of most things
oh wait what if it's just like not
merciful
isn't that it isn't that the only thing
really
[Music]
see thruster claws that's it that's it
that was the only difference it's just
like the non-merciful version
uh who you all consumed by flames
that's it
that's the last one a letter flutters
down from beyond the curtains you found
lost letter number one
i got the letters
my love
it just isn't fair at all is it
for them to force us apart like this
it's unreasonable cruel i had to find an
outlet for this grief somehow
so i decided to write and i'll keep
writing
till the day you find me once more
and then
maybe we could write a story together
i'm waiting for that day
forever yours tragedy
so there's something else it can't end
like this
you want to answer the maiden's prayers
you've decided to find a way to save
everyone but retracing the paths you've
seen so far there doesn't seem to be any
room to avoid a bad ending is there
really nothing you can do to keep them
all from getting killed in the end
if there's nothing you could do by
acting from within their story
maybe it's time to take things into your
own hands
oh what oh god
underling on f on fire
what
oh
you boldly insert yourself into the
story and use your incredible power to
warp everyone to safety
you didn't know you could do that but
what's going on here you take a moment
to get a good look at yourself you are
you but why are you pitch black you feel
that this body doesn't accurately
represent you but you move past it the
hero maiden underling and overlord have
all been staring at you they look like
they don't really know what they're
supposed to do right now you guess
that's because you're usually the one
guiding them what will you say to them
hi hello everybody my name is markiplier
subscribe bb on youtube.com markiplier
hi you smile awkwardly and introduce
yourself the maiden is the first to
respond my prayers have been answered
you must be her god
well
maybe a little bit
maybe a lot of a bit
maybe it's not a bit at all uh no you're
near the the player if there was any god
here they'd be the final boss that's
just how these role-playing gods and
games go
now you realize what the real true
ending must be
now now now enough of this
i admit i've been encouraging you all
along but a self-insert story how posse
you watch helplessly as tragedy descends
from the heavens
you didn't honestly believe you were the
only one who could force your way onto
this stage
did you
i am the narrator storyteller god of
this world
call me tragedy if you'd like
darkness envelops your party you don't
mind if i send each of them back to
relive one of their many bad endings to
you
you are alone in the darkness with me
tragedy
i sincerely hope you've enjoyed your
time in my theater
though i can't abide you stealing the
show without permission
it's quite disrespectful
i'm sick of all the bells show me some
new
uh well i mean i don't mind the best
yeah it's new please are you trying to
say my bad endings have gone out of
style
you have some nerve you think defeating
me might just be the only way to see a
better ending
it's all that's left for you isn't it
well this does sound like it could be
entertaining
show me what you've got
time to fight god i didn't think i was
ready for this but okay
if you're sitting on the bench you got
to be ready to play
the stage is set for your final battle
against me
the god of this world
what will you do how would you fight
against tragedy itself i'd love to see
it
i
defend
you try closing off your heart to
protect yourself but it doesn't make you
feel any better
or is that all you'll never defeat me
like that
wait let me try that again
[Music]
perhaps you don't understand just how
class you are
behold my beautifully strategic tales
doesn't seem them all again make your
heart ache
you've witnessed fall forty one of my
painstakingly crafted endings you must
be as much of a masochist as me
i commend your thoroughness surely these
characters have a special place in your
heart
they're still suffering backstage you
know
it's a shame they couldn't make it here
to the end of the world
that's right
you came here to save them
you can't do this alone
oh
simon call friend
oh
you find the hero in his own hunched
over a sewing table your sudden
intrusion scares the hell out of the
poor guy
are you some kind of demon you explain
that no you're not a demon you're
how can you explain it in a way that the
hero can understand instead you ask what
he's sewing know this i craft all my own
hero gear you sense his pride in his
hobby you wonder if the costumes are
what attracted him to the role of hero
would you like some clothes you don't
seem to be wearing any
i am naked yes you remember the state of
your body and decide that yes some
clothes from the hero would be nice he
is overjoyed by your answer apparently
his outfits are too gaudy for the other
townsfolk so no one else wants him the
true end for the hero suddenly becomes
clear he offered to change his fate i
could make a living as a tailor rather
than a hero please tell me what i can do
to reach that dream the hero will now
fight alongside you
oh i agreed to follow you but i didn't
expect to face something like this
the hero has arrived we really couldn't
have a final boss battle without him
you're the one who's been killing us
murderer i can't truly call myself a
hero until i see you defeated
you'll see about that tragedy attacks
with a terrible fate ow
ow
uh salmon
you happen to find the maiden as she
exits the church perfect timing she
approaches you having already taken
notice of your odd form
excuse me are you a traveler i've never
seen anyone like you before
you explain that no you're not a
traveler well maybe you are in a sense
you've come all this way the main
regards you with excited curiosity that
perhaps you might be a demon i was
hoping i would meet one today you think
of all the terrible fates that would
that would hope would bring about she is
the catalyst of this story after all my
role as a maiden is to be captured by
the overlord but you see i've grown so
tired of waiting you remember this part
she wanted to understand her role better
and so you ask what it is that she's
really hoping to gain from this
maiden is confused by your question
perhaps it was as simple as wanting to
reach the place she felt like she
belonged the true end for the maiden
becomes suddenly clear
you offer to change your fate
if there's something i can do to find
fulfillment then please guide me
the maiden will now fly alongside you
what is this horrible creature
you wound me dear maiden his tragedy
really such a terrible thing to behold i
remember now i remember all the awful
things you put us through then this
should be familiar to you as well
tragedy attacks with a terrible fate
now
well
let's keep going then
you approach the gates of the overlord's
castle the underling his own guard duty
as you expected they call out to you the
other demon guard is sound asleep
hey you're pretty weird-looking intruder
what do you want you explain that no
you're not an intruder although you're
definitely intruding into their story
right now you tell the underling that
you've come to save them from tragedy
okay try saving me from boredom first i
hate this job the underling snickers you
asked what kind of job they'd rather
have
it'd be best if i didn't have to work at
all i just want to live a carefree life
and never get boss around or picked on
you think of the underling's friends who
had bullied them into assassination plot
only to portray them in the end
if they kept better company maybe they
wouldn't feel so restless a true end for
the underling suddenly becomes clear you
offered to change their fate so there's
a way for that to even work can be that
even work can be fun sounds fake but
i'll tag along with you just in case the
underling will not fight alongside you
wait what the [ __ ] you didn't say
anything about a boss battle
the underling
you must be desperate to call on such an
unreliable ally
if i beat this guy up all my problems
will be over oh but it won't be that
easy
tragedy attacks with a terrible fate
i'm having too much fun
now
all right how about this hi-yah
you enter the overlord's room relieved
to see that the fire contained at the
torches on the wall when you close it or
behind you the overload rises from her
slumber
who are you have you come to reside in
my castle and serve me
you explain that no you're not here to
serve her it's more like you've come to
do her a favor you ask why she spends
all day sleeping instead of commanding
her demon army she laughs in response
many of my underlings certainly think i
should be more aggressive with the
humans like my father before me
his quest for revenge was endless and
self-perpetuating there's a reason i had
to destroy him
you can't help but think it's a little
late in the game to get some backstory
i have no interest of waging war on
humans i merely wish to be left alone to
live a peaceful indulgent life in my
castle you realize she must actually be
very lonely only surrounded by soldiers
instead of friends no wonder she gets so
attached to the maiden the true end for
the overlord suddenly becomes clear you
offered to change your fate
my own attempts peace have been rather
imperfect if you offer a solution then
very well
i will follow you
the other lord will now fight alongside
you
i see so this is tragedy
you've prevented me from attaining peace
for so long
prepare to die
[Music]
i hope you're prepared to face your
destiny
tragedy attacks with them
er
i guess
[Music]
now that the whole party's here can you
solve my final puzzle
which combinations of behavior will
sheriff in the past deal true ending
show me
all right so the true ending becomes
clear
will oh
your reign of tower and terror ends here
tragedy i refuse to give in
the hero uses the will power to overcome
tragedy
the tragedy is reeling
okay how about some
ho
boom
how true endings do exist they simply
must the man hopes with all her heart to
overcome tragedy
tragedy is reeling
how
little about little mischief
how about a little mischief
the underling tries to evade tragedy
through mischievous means
you're so much fun would you like oh
whoops oh i will hang on yeah yeah
you're right tenacity knock me down and
i'll just come back stronger the
underling uses their tenacity to
overcome tragedy
tragedy is reeling all right how about
ambition
i'll reach my true ending with my own
power
the overlord uses her ambitious nature
to become tragedy
this is it with everyone's hearts united
you take aim for your best possible
futures
you unleash one final attack to destroy
tragedy once and for all
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you've done it you've managed to defeat
me
a tragic end for tragedy itself
i love it
i must thank you all for fulfilling your
roles
perfectly
thank you hero
thank you maiden
thank you handling
thank you
overlord
not of this nonsense we defeated you so
die already
don't worry i'll be making my exit
shortly
firstly thank you most of all
we couldn't have made it here without
you
yes my
bad end theater did contain a truly good
ending after all
i apologize for antagonizing you for so
long i wanted to deliver a satisfying
story
was i able to do it
i wonder
no
no
well i did my best
happy endings shouldn't always come
easily oh i was gonna say no as in you
should have a happy ending reality is
not so kind but you've earned this one
here's a true ending oh
[Music]
but i
i meant that as in
i meant that as in uh
as in i was assuming that would lead to
me saying something like you deserve a
better ending
[Music]
is
[Music]
wandering all alone searching for my
lost
[Music]
thinking of your face
for all your
my
tragedy
i knew it i
knew it i
knew something's missing
i knew it i love that song by the way
it's very good
oh
you're still here
the curtain has closed for the final
time
i'm shutting down my theater
there are no more tragedies left for me
to tell after all
as tragedy it's story
me
you'd like to know why i started this
theater
because i'm obsessed with bad endings of
course
[Music]
you generally raise your fingers to the
cracks in my mask
piece by piece it falls apart in your
hands revealing
[Music]
i should have warned you this might
affect what you think of my stories
you can't help but compare my face to
the maidens
i'm not her
but it's not like she isn't me
necessarily that's how it is with
fiction
would you like to hear
not another ending but
the truth
tell me
all right one last story
you may already know this one but
it doesn't have a happy ending
first i'll set the stage
in this world there are no such things
as demons or even heroes really
there was a girl easier to set out to
fulfill some sort of destiny that part
was true
she met someone
another girl
a running theme isn't it
the maiden and the overlord
the two were inseparable and for a time
everything was just wonderful
but their families the communities they
came from
neither could approve of their
relationship
that's the reality for many
this pair was no different
despite their best efforts the world was
intent on pulling them apart
she
no
we
we used to like the types of stories
where love conquers all
where the strength of your love will
pull you through any hardship and
everything is okay in the end
i lost her
and then i started this theater
huh
oh
i was hoping to find you
it's you
it's been so long
i thought i'd never see you again
you always think of the worst endings
i wasn't about to give up just because
things got difficult
why didn't you reveal yourself sooner i
feel like such a fool
i could say the same to you
you knew i could never resist giving
your stories a happy ending
so of course i would be
drawn to a place like this
yes
i didn't think it would actually work
sometimes everything does turn out okay
in the end
thank you for reminding me of that
i love you
i love you too
oh
now truly everyone can live happily ever
after
tragedies end
that's really sweet
that's really sweet
god
[Laughter]
dull and then the whole theater engulfs
in flames when they all burn together no
that was great i liked that a lot that
was very good i can see why people were
really into this game i mean i was
really into it i played the whole damn
thing very fun i mean i'm a sucker for
choose your own adventures that kind of
stuff and this is like an innovative
twist on it and oh man just
very fun hope you guys didn't mind me
indulging myself with the voices
i thought that was wonderful so thank
you everybody so much for watching
support this developer link to this game
is in the description below play for
yourself i mean i think i got all the
endings but definitely show some love to
them play the game experience it for
yourself maybe there's secrets that i
don't even know there's probably some
kind of accommodation in there i didn't
get to four choices for four people
a lot of choices maybe there's a secret
of one in there who knows and not every
story has a happy ending not every story
has a bad ending but it was a good
ending after all in here so thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you